we broke up will and I really break it
down I was devastated even worse than a
divorce
Will Smith choking up on wife Jada
Pinkett Smith's Facebook watch show red
Tabletalk he's at a time in his life to
where he is he's healing you know and
he's also kind of breaking down some of
the construct that he's built around
himself of who he is and who he's not
and all of those kinds of things so I
actually think that this has been kind
of him coming to the table it has been
kind of a release for him to not have to
live up to this certain thing yeah yeah
exactly
it takes a lot of work and it's not easy
and it can be painful so and I'm proud
of them on part one of their sit-down as
a couple revealed new details about how
their romance began I remember you were
on different world yes and Alphonso knew
everybody and I remember the first time
I saw you actually think I've dated
Alphonse you went on a date with our
Father yes he like took you on a
motorcycle or something so yeah my
memory is updated a lot of people yeah
sure yeah but we went on one day I know
buddy
so Alfonzo knew you I was like yo dude I
saw this girl on different world but
last night Oh her name is Jada dude he
said oh yeah yeah boy knows he can
introduce you will and Alfonzo went to a
taping of a different world but things
didn't go as planned Alf was like yo
that's my boy that knows when he sat
down and I was like yo who's that girl
he's with I was like at the dude that
was gonna introduce you great was with
another girl and I was like who is that
girl
and it was Sheree he went to I went to
different world to meet Jade
and ended up marrying sharee and having
trade with sure it didn't meet Jada that
day Will and Jada wound up connecting
years later I had a realization that I
wasn't with the person I was supposed to
be with but you would have stayed with
her forever forever I would have never
gotten divorced
yeah sure II wound up filing for divorce
from well but it had nothing to do with
Jada we did not have an affair did not
have a nice marriage
loud and clear will said he signed his
divorce papers and immediately called
Jada I said good I saw are you seeing
anybody
oh my god and she said no I said cool
you're seeing me now dumbass okay the
pair's been together ever since but it
hasn't been all bliss in fact their
marriage came close to ending externally
our family was winning right and there
was a period where mommy woke up and
cried 45 days straight I started keeping
a diary damn you missed some days it was
every morning I think that's the worst
I've ever felt in our marriage Wow I was
failing miserably will admits he put all
his energy into presenting a perfect
picture to the outside world this was
around the time the couple's kids Jaden
and Willow became famous in their own
right if there were an individual most
poisonous aspect of our relationship in
the past is I felt that money and
winning made a good relationship
there'll be more with will next week and
a lot more to come this season on red
Tabletalk will is our first guest
I also brought Leah Remini we've got Jay
Cole coming we had we have a lot of
great guests we're talking about issues
like domestic violence we're talking
about love and marriage we're talking
about this all kind of stuff
it's gonna be it's gonna be a really
great year
[Music]